I always was troubled by sort of the
Great Compromise you know of Henry Clay
and people typically have said oh well
that kept us from going into war and he
was a great man because he he kept us
from going into war but I always thought
well maybe he chose the wrong compromise
hi I'm Nick Gillespie with Reason TV I'm
joined by Matt Welch of Reason magazine
and today we're interviewing Senator
Rand Paul of Kentucky thanks for talking
with us senator good to be with you you
when you came into office you
immediately dressed and Republican
proposals to cut 2011 spending by sixty
1 billion dollars calling instead for
five hundred billion in cuts our first
question is why are your cut so small
well that's the same question I get when
I go to a tea party up here everybody's
like oh it's so dramatic you we could
never do that and I go to a tea party
event they'll say well that's only a
third of one year's deficit you need to
cut more what what kind of response did
you get from fellow Republican
legislators mostly just that they
couldn't comprehend it at all if I did
get any direct response is that they
won't consider anything that has any
cuts to the military in it so but I
think that's what's useful in bringing
it out and talking about it one it's
useful to look at the details because if
you don't look at the details and you
just simply say oh I'm for a balanced
budget amendment
every Republican up here is for a
balanced budget amendment but as you can
see a lot of them aren't for cutting any
federal spending well and then on the
dumber I mean you've talked about it in
a recent speech you said that we can't
keep doubling the defense budget which
we've done in the past few years and
expect to balance the budget that's on
the Republican side they seem totally
unwilling or incapable of really
entertaining serious cuts to the defense
budget to bring it back to where was in
2000 it's not like we're talking about
going peacetime but then on the
Democratic side its entitlement spending
and Social Services
well that's worse than that it's even
worse than that on the Democratic side
the president's proposal is to take 12%
of the budget non-military discretionary
spending and freeze it at 2010 levels
after he increased it by 25% so for
example here's how bad it is on the
Democrat side on the FAA bill it would
have been 17 billion dollars I
introduced an amendment
just to take it back to 2008 levels
would have saved two billion dollars not
one Democrat voted for it but all the
Republicans did so you can bring along
the Republicans are willing to be
brought along and I think many will come
more in our direction but the Democrats
really aren't for cutting any spending I
mean they said they wanted to cut the
other day what four billion for the rest
of the year that's how much we borrow in
one day we spend ten billion in one day
in your new book the Tea Party goes to
Washington you say one of the chapters
is called we don't have a revenue
problem so we have a spending problem is
the implication how do we how do we
bring it back to normalcy where you know
we're actually spending something like
what we take in Ryan it's hard because
if you look at the increase for example
George Bush's last steps it was five
hundred billion and I complained I said
that was awful that was big government
republicanism and everything I thought
was wrong and now we've tripled that you
are a hawk within the Republican
minority caucus in the Senate what are
you attempting to do with yourself how
do you approach your work in the next
you know term basically I think some of
what I do is to help Drive and pull the
debate in the direction I think it needs
to go for example when the Republicans
originally came out in the house with 30
billion we came out with 500 billion and
they didn't come to the 500 but they
came and were honest to go back at least
to their pledge of a hundred billion and
so I think it helps to bring in them
around
I'd like to crunch the numbers and so we
put out numbers we put out the 500
billion we said where we would cut it
mainly because I didn't like doing media
interviews and people go where you gonna
cut you're not really gonna cut because
where is it and I do want credibility
and so I we put out exactly where we'd
cut to 500 billion but it also shows you
that it can be done we did that without
doing entitlement cuts so it's amazing
there's a lot to be had there but it
only happens if you take the philosophic
view that the federal government should
be limited in what it does and that a
lot of functions that it's accumulated
over the last 70 years really should be
handled by the states and the people but
I think people were ready for that part
of the Tea Party movement was also this
10th amendment movement you know stuff
not enumerated should have been left to
the states and the people and so I think
it is useful to talk about that but we
talked about eliminating whole
departments Department
Department of Energy Department of
Commerce HUD we talked about sending
those functions back where they should
be how do you come up with that like how
do what what is the cost-benefit
analysis that you say okay education
it's gone commerce that's gone right
well it's it isn't too hard or too big a
stretch to go for the department
education because it was part of the
Republican platform from 1980 to 2000 it
was one of the reasons that motivated me
to run was that we were doing the
opposite of getting rid of it we were
doubling it you know yeah under Bush we
had No Child Left Behind which I think
doubled the employees and doubled the
funding we're up to about a hundred
billion dollars and if you look at test
scores and think test scores are fairly
flat so I don't think you can claim that
we have aided education by all this
federal money same way of like
Washington DC those who believe money
helps education we're now spending
twenty thousand dollars per pupil and we
still have some of the worst education
in the country as far scores go in DC so
I think there is a Republican history
for getting with the Department of
Education and there's empirical evidence
that doesn't seem to be helping
education right after let's talk about
your relationship with in the Republican
Party right after the November election
your colleague Jim DeMint in the Senate
told Fox News that quote you can't be a
fiscal conservative and not be a social
conservative do you agree with that I
don't know I think the thing is is that
for me the preeminent issues are the
fiscal issues and I don't really see a
relationship I think that a lot of
people are fiscally conservative are
also socially conservative if you talk
to most members of the Tea Party I think
the vast would be fiscally conservative
and socially conservative I don't think
it's necessarily a prerequisite that
they're one links to the other that you
have to be both and I think that really
for me the most important problem facing
the nation and facing the future of our
country really is the debt and that we
could have a debt crisis in our country
do you actually think that I mean are we
on a tipping point where it's like we we
go the way of Greece we go the way of
countries that just run out of money
Argentina yeah my concern right now and
I'm actually more concerned in the last
three days because of what's going on in
Japan I don't think things are always
mathematical I think that sometimes
things happen in a panic and a flurry I
think when the crisis came on a year and
a half ago it didn't seem to be
mathematical it was out of proportion
even to the events but the government
was stoking at the government ever
was saying panic panic we have to pass
this or the stock market will go down
then they didn't pass it and loan them
to hold the stock bar they talked to the
stock market down but the why I'm
worried about Japan is is that many
people have been saying that Japan is
now before this natural disaster has
passed the point of no return as far as
accumulating debt and there are smart
people who look at the sovereign debt
crisis and they say Japan's within two
or three years of it well what do you
think just happened I'm we might have
sped that up by a couple years ago may
have a devastating amount of money
that's going to be necessary to rebuild
Japan and so I fear that being pushed up
because those same people that saves
your pain is coming think that we're a
year or two behind Japan I don't know if
it necessarily correlates that we will
move up in that scale too but as Japan
has a crisis it will lead to panics of
confidence around the world I think
you're on your when you won the election
your election night speech didn't
mention the word Republican Republican
party once and nor does I think the
title of this book talked a bit why
you're emphasizing the tea parties so
much and even independents who use sort
of a flag is a separate beast that
you're engaging with I've always thought
the issues are more important than the
party and I think there are a lot of
people out there who wants somebody who
believes passionately in small limited
constitutional government people want to
be left alone from the nanny state but
they aren't all Republican some of them
are independent some of them are
libertarian some of those might be
Democrats as well but I think they also
don't like when when you see these polls
that say oh people don't like the the
rhetoric or the partisanship what they
don't like his empty partisanship I
don't think they mind you and I having a
real discussion and disagreeing on an
issue they don't like us to yell
necessarily but they don't mind a good
spirited discussion on both sides but
they don't like me just disliking you
because you're a Democrat or a
libertarian they want me to engage on
issues and so I think that it is more
important what the issues are so people
say is the Tea Party more important than
the Republican Party say no but the debt
problem is more important than party and
if the Republicans want to propose more
problem or big government programs like
the Medicare prescription drug plan or
No Child Left Behind I'll oppose that
but that's what the Tea Party wants and
that's where I the tea party I think is
good is I say that they're equal parts
chastisement to both parties because
both parties have led us down on spend
and all all the juice in American
politics basically since tarp and the
bailouts have been in that direction
even if it's not specifically Tea Party
it's been in the direction towards
cutting the size of government freaking
out about it and reacting that way why
is it taken so long for people who work
around here to realize that well there
is a disconnect and and my dad used to
always say that there's a lag time you
know maybe a few years between what's
going on in America and what's going on
in Washington and there's the lag time
because maybe they're not truly
connected to the people that well
they're not home as much as they used to
be there's also a lag time because those
in Washington are more concerned about
furthering their career and who do we
see every day that comes in the office
somebody with their hand out wanting
money not poor people rich people come
in here with their hand out and
corporations special interest lobbyists
they all want something in fact one of
my favorite little signs or stories was
there's a Michigan congressman who's
elected he's got to sign up in his
office and it says if you've come
looking for money you're in the wrong
office but that's what happens so they
get influenced by the wrong people and
they also are self-preservation they
want it they want to stay here once they
get here and to stay here they think you
have to please the the lobbyists and I
think the I think the opposite may be
true see like they don't want to talk
about Social Security in fact they don't
want me to talk about Social Security
I'm going to anyway because well let's
just say official official Washington
but anyway you know because they they
they don't want us out in front of the
issue they want the President to absorb
some of the blow when you talk about
intolerant reform they think there will
be blows but I think even politically
they've miscalculated because I think
people are hungry for someone who will
step up and say this is what's wrong and
this is what I'm gonna do to fix it look
at who look at the reaction of chris
Christie he's nothing if nothing else
he's Frankie's to the point and he's
unafraid to say what's wrong and all of
a sudden people respect that and I think
even some of the media seems to be
paying him some respect so I think it's
a wrong political strategy it's also
wrong for the country just to sit back
and not try to lead us out of the
problems we have one of your yeah I mean
you've had a number of remarkable
moments rhetorically one was your speech
where you talked about Henry Clay the
great Kentucky senator
and how he was wrong to talk about to be
the great compromiser so what what kind
of response did you get from fellow
Kentuckians and what does it mean to say
no compromise does that mean that you're
a dogmatic ideologue or does it mean
that you're a man of principle
well I always was troubled by sort of
the great compromise you know of Henry
Clay and people typically have said oh
well that kept us from going into war
and he was a great man because he he
kept us from going into war but I always
thought well maybe he chose the wrong
compromise you know there's nothing
wrong necessarily or absolutely with
compromise but what if you choose a
compromise that keeps people enslaved
and owned is that a time when you
compromise so I think there are certain
things you probably shouldn't compromise
over and I can't compare and contrast
him with other people for example his
cousin Cassius Clay Cassius Marcellus
clay who was a famous abolitionist in
Kentucky somebody refused to compromise
and he was stabbed beaten chased through
the streets and I guess I have more
respect for that and I think if you look
at history all along politicians because
they're famous and their names out there
get a lot of recognition but there's a
famous quote about Lincoln that I like
it's from one of the 37th Congress
Republicans the Radical Republicans and
one of them said that we need to make
sure in history that Lincoln doesn't
live on borrowed plumage because they
were the ones fighting for emancipation
dragging Lincoln long all the way it was
good that he finally came and so we can
say yeah it was a great president
because he finally came to emancipation
but like when I read history in high
school my history textbook would have
said William Lloyd Garrison was just a
religious zealot and he wasn't they
always had disdain somewhat for some of
the abolitionists and they were the true
people who believed in things they were
true believers talk a little bit about
your formative intellectual and
ideological background like where I mean
obviously your father Ron Paul is a very
powerful or very influential politician
perhaps not so powerful but where does
it come from do you go back and forth it
seems between calling yourself a
libertarian or a constitutional
conservative what does what does that
mean what's the distinction you're
drawing there I'm a believer in very
limited government government limited by
a document a constitutional government
now a lot most people in America would
I believe in that too but it really is
more specific than that that the
government only enumerated the
Constitution only enumerated certain
powers for the federal Congress to be
involved with and I think whether you
say that's a libertarian or not people I
think libertarians become a better term
that once was but it still scares some
people and it's used by some people to
scare others particularly in the south
and different places people use it as a
as a weapon to try to scare people what
well I think that they're not sure what
that means what the word means although
I would say that since the the George W
Bush era when the term conservative
became somewhat meaningless that now a
lot of people and you'll see boohoo
probably really are more traditional
conservative saying wanting to use the
word libertarian because it's more
distinctive term so in some ways it has
come into better usage now in the among
the common public but I think people
understand constitutional conservative
better at least where I'm from than they
do the word libertarian but I think they
can mean somewhat the same thing now on
your bookshelf behind you I see Judge
Napolitano I see Ludwig von Mises you're
obscuring the copy of Marx back there
but who were who were your insight in
the art of a motorcycle man yeah Robert
piercing so and Flannery O'Connor this
is yeah
I you know I think that I have some one
eclectic background I like literature I
was a English minor and in school and
science because I went into medicine but
I was always a big fan of the short
story big fan of Dostoevsky as far as a
novelist goes but I read a lot of the
free market people and it was influenced
by that I met quite a few of them along
the way you know Amit Han sent Holtz
several times
Mises only had four PhDs met Murray
Rothbard through the year so you know I
was exposed to a lot of them Henry
Hazlitt you know we were talking about
getting some books for the interns you
know when they come and I thought they
should all have Henry Hazlitt second ah
mcc's in one lesson in Basquiat so the
law has two things that they leave our
office and had been here they can say
this is what I got from the senator you
know so those are two things we're gonna
give them if the Republican Party
doesn't absorb and act on the message
from the tea party by 2012
then what what's a what's a logical next
step I think circumstances will
determine what happens in a way I think
we're all being forced more and more to
become fiscal conservatives or to at
least address the problem they're not
addressing it because they want to if we
had an abundance of money up here right
now it'd be the same as usual but there
there is a shortage of money right now
we historically brought in about 18% of
GDP
we're down around 15% of GDP but that's
because we have a big recession but part
of this is a debate and discussion about
ideas because I tell people if you think
that the Great Recession that we're in
or the worst recession since the Great
Depression if you think it was a failure
of capitalism then we need more
regulations unfortunately that's what
most of them think up here is that it
was a failure of capitalism so I use the
word capitalism all the time people say
oh you shouldn't use capitalism you
should call it free enterprise or
something like that but I think
capitalism is a great word and it's you
know I call it democratic capitalism
because everybody says they want the
right to vote well heck yeah you get to
vote every day in the marketplace over
which goods you choose which businesses
succeed and it's a way of winnowing out
the most efficient producers of products
and goods but I think that I'm not sure
that they're quite there yet but I think
circumstances may bring us there as the
the debt I really think we could face a
debt crisis within five years what you
know judging from your recent
confrontation with a Department of
Energy a bureaucrat let's say your top
official actually in which you've ran
down deed mandates for compact
fluorescent light bulbs and for low-flow
toilets and things like that you seem to
be enjoying yourself more than any
senator since Ted Kennedy about five
minutes before Chappaquiddick what what
it you know what it what are you doing
to stay a happy warrior well I had
really planned on doing that I came in
here and sat down and thought you know
what because I just read an article from
the Competitive Enterprise Institute
talking about how there in every aspect
of your house no matter which room you
walk into they're telling you what you
can buy and what you can install and I'd
read through the years all those Dave
Barry editorials about the toilets and I
have the toilets right after they passed
the law built my house and got the worst
they finally worked out some of the
problems but mine were installed in like
96 and they don't work
and I just get mad you know that all of
these things that they want to tell us
thing buy and they don't even grasp it
you know because when I asked the woman
are you pro-choice and she said oh boy
in lightbulbs it's like that's the
opposite of what she is she doesn't want
to let me choose what kind of lightbulb
I can buy and I think that they're so
far out of tune they don't get even get
it but I think if you can bring the
debate to says something like that
that's more interesting when if you've
ever sat through one of these committee
hearings it's usually about the minutiae
and the detail and that's why no one
keepin watch this without their eyes
rolling in the back of their head on
television but hopefully on occasion
I'll be able to make it interesting and
talk a little bit about the underlying
philosophy of should government be doing
this or shouldn't government be doing
this you gave a great talk in front of
the camera about the Patriot Act
reauthorization and the history of the
Fourth Amendment and as it has happened
a couple of times when have watched you
talk I just had to kept writing myself
he is a Republican he is a Republican I
sort of startling what kind of response
have you gotten from Republican
colleagues when you say things like this
and have any Democrats suddenly become
friendlier to someone they obviously
think is interesting I've learned some
things from some other colleagues I
think there's a few others that may come
over to some of our reforms they didn't
vote for app not extending it but they
may come for some of the amendments
we're gonna offer some amendments and
some reforms and one of the things I've
learned a little more about I'm not an
attorney it was about administrative
subpoenas and that interestingly the
National Security Letters have less
protection than an administrative
subpoena because if I serve a subpoena
on you and say I want your bank records
or I want this information from you you
can call your lawyer go to court and try
to quash it so you have some judicial
review before I do it the NSLs you have
none of that so that the conservatives
try to tell us oh they're just subpoenas
what's the big deal we're just getting
bank records we've always done that it's
just a subpoena but it's done in secret
so you don't know and you haven't even
if it weren't done in secret if you're
informed at first you weren't even
allowed to tell your attorney now you're
allowed to tell your attorney but I
don't think you have any recourse you
can't go to a court and say we want to
stop them from doing this we want to
have a judicial hearing it doesn't exist
and the idea of judicial review is a
pretty important thing in our society
and the idea that we wouldn't have
policemen our
holder's making decisions and I don't
think they're bad people I mean I know a
lot of FBI agents they're not bad people
they want to do what's right but in
doing what's right they might become a
little overzealous and without the
restraint of having to go through a
judge what are you optimistic in well
I'll wrap up with this you know you're
talking about a sovereign debt crisis in
five years you're talking about you know
an out-of-control surveillance state
spending that is unstopping ly
unstoppable are you optimistic about the
future or not I mean you know and at the
same time everything in American life
for many things seemed to be getting
better and then on this side they're
getting no I'm optimistic about the
engine of capitalism what freedom can do
I mean we make incredible amount of
prosperity and wealth in this country I
mean almost unstoppable but as the
government gets bigger and bigger there
is probably eventually a breaking point
also I think you know there is while we
have great prosperity right now there's
also 10% of the people unemployed
there's another five or ten that aren't
ever getting jobs there are whole
segments of our countryside and economy
where people just aren't working and
they're addicted to drugs and they're
just kind of sitting around collecting a
check and and and abusing drugs which I
think sometimes go hand in hand if
you're idle you're just just letting
around doing nothing and I think so
those problems exist and but I do worry
about what happens if we have a
significant crisis you know were you
either because they don't think we quit
paying our debt when you can't pay your
debt you print more money if that
accelerates then I think you can have a
destruction of your currency the other
thing is is half of our currencies
overseas you know we've been exporting
our inflation forever we import a lot of
goods we send our dollars overseas they
buy our debt but it stays over there and
so we don't have the chasing our Goods
if that ever comes back in a in a crisis
of confidence like in a you know in a
several week period then I think you
know you can have chaos but I think
being here also I don't know if we're
gonna have that or not nobody knows the
future but I think you do want to have
people in place who believe in in the
American system of capitalism in case we
have chaos and you know I'd get in
trouble on the campaign trail for
criticism I'll say I get in trouble I
don't send me to the principal's office
but I get criticism because you know I
would talk about how in when
currency was destroyed 1923 they voted
in Hitler and if I sell you're comparing
someone hey I'm not comparing anyone -
I'm just saying that in the times of
crisis
even a panicky public can vote in
someone who says give me your Liberty
and I'll give you security and I don't
want that to happen and so I think the
best way is all these things can be
gradually reformed I mean some of the
Rotarians give me a hard time because
I'm going to try to reform Social
Security rather than just privatize it
I'd love to privatize it I'd love to
have individual accounts but the first
step we're gonna do is try to fix it by
just letting the age gradually rise
means testing the benefits things that
aren't perfect libertarian utopias but
you got to fix I think some of the
entitlement programs just in order not
to face this budgetary crisis it's
coming thank you I'm Nick Gillespie for
Reason TV with Matt Welch of Reason
magazine we want to thank Senator Rand
Paul of Kentucky for taking time to talk
with us - thank you